I use an interpreter
it's the shortened version of my last
name which is co-op and it has always
been like my nickname when I was playing
a football as a kid since I was like 10
years old and people have told me that
and so I decided to just go of that
because I'm not good at making up names
I started playing League of Legends in
season one nothing I was only playing
all games with friends and like playing
for fun and then in season two I started
playing ranked and since then I like to
kind of quit the normal games and
started playing myself for a triple kill
I was getting really good followers I
was in my last year of high school my
parents even though they supported me
with the gaming thing they still wanted
me to finish high school and at the same
time I was getting really good and maybe
had the chance to go pro earlier but I
decided to finish high school and then
one month after I graduated I do qualify
to LCS with Dignitas I have a close
friend group who am all actually very
supportive and now watch all of our
games we play in LCS that friend group
was once I started playing and like
normal games with and kinda ditched them
to pursue my gaming career
spent looking for the engage underneath
this cow very tanky he's got you brick
but well he can take now you can take
this tower for centuries and now they'll
move on to cetera and he goes down
triple kill over the car be he just
destroys the line cause I had some
criticisms but maybe not as much as
autoplay yourself I think it's kind of
easier to deal with you shouldn't let it
get to a hit because that's when it can
screw you mostly you can just read the
comments if they're lame you could laugh
about it
we were like completely new team with
like four rookies so we had to learn the
game and get experience on stage it was
like the main problem I would say
there's a clear difference between a
despot and Mickey when this video is
more like focused on macro and with
Mickey is like a really mechanically
gifted player it allows me to do a lot
more when he's playing Thresh abort and
landing all these skill shots and then
he sets me up for success so that has a
big part that's wrong this is the
running contests but we have Nicky X
coming in to support copy as well the
Kalima Silas kill for copy was not
expecting Lucien to come in that same
coops and wonder I've known them for a
couple of years now and through my
friendship or relationship with them
because I kinda I got into the Danish
team through them then we started
playing international tournaments which
eventually turn into Dignitas and into
every runner but wonders not letting
them go anywhere glacial fissure popping
up Cabo shark goes in and gets melted
the rest right now I'm really happy with
where we are and I think in Springfield
I didn't play that good individually but
it's kind of like also if you play ad
carry for a losing team then it's hard
to look good but at the same time I
wasn't playing that well on stage so I
can mostly being myself for that but now
all of us are feeling confident on stage
and
shows in our games as like we get along
really well also out of the game and
especially in game we can talk openly
about things we want to do different and
stuff so there's no personal feelings
coming in between which i think is
really good